It,
this,
it all,
uh,
relevant what happened in VA,
the bed.
I was that,
uh,
you got your basic cop car coming along
and it wasn't rolling aggressively.
I,
it was about a saying about
50 kilometers an hour.
And these two young,
uh,
north African extraction,
use,
uh,
without helmets,
were,
uh,
didn't yield to the car.
They were on a scooter,
you know,
sort of essentially a motorcycle,
not a big one,
but you know,
it's good hair.
And so that they hit the
car on the left side.
Unfortunately they were both
killed and then the police,
um,
state a bit and made calls.
But the calls that they made were more,
you know,
we have something spinning out of control.
It's not about how are
these two kids who are,
and you see,
they,
they left it there for two days.
They circled it always.
So you still see these
little guys tennis shoes,
you know,
and you see,
you can see the traces of them.
They're having expired.
And so VDA a Labella,
which is about 18
kilometers north of Paris.
It's near Yc,
it's near [inaudible] where
there's a lot of trouble.
Before it was near.
They're going ass.
It's in the,
in the [inaudible] um,
went up in flames basically in a lot.
Unfortunately,
a lot of people were
hurt in the fighting and,
and yesterday they burn
somebody who stupidly burned
the library and the library
is not associated with the fleet,
with the cops is not
associated with the state.
Even it is the municipal library
where lots of kids go and study in the
municipal library.
And so this was just,
you know,
Nocona Hey,
I mean this is not possible
to do stuff like that.
But anyway,
the part of the problem is,
and cause Sarcosy,
you know,
denigrated the people in the suburbs.
There's an archive,
you know,
as scum by implication,
uh,
that,
and uh,
was minister of the interior
during the big troubles.
And a couple of years ago,
which I'm going to talk
about on Wednesday,
the troubles we're starting clichy Suva,
but there's a lot of,
in Toulouse where they had been trouble,
uh,
two years ago.
Now it's happening in two news too,
but I didn't,
I'll watch it this afternoon,
but it's,
this is a problem.
It's going to be a,
it's gonna be a problem for a while.
And what's makes it a little more scary
is that this was an incident where they
have an instance where the police are,
you know,
the police systematically control
people of color systematically in,
in France,
systematically.
I go through Barbara Joie Schwab,
which is a,
uh,
is a metro stop,
a famous for this first place that
somebody shot and killed a German officer.
And during Vishi and uh,
or the Guard Leo,
I was there then Garland,
garland will not the other day,
but at the end of uh,
November or for that matter,
after Sarcozi was elected,
you go to the garden,
the own metro stop.
And also when you turn the corner
and then you got 10 policemen,
they're controlling people.
I've lived in,
I spent half my life in
France for the last 30 years.
I've never been controlled.
Not once,
not once.
And I've been with people going through
and that you turn the corner and all of
a sudden you've got all the,
the police there.
And who do they pick out?
They don't pick out,
you know,
whites carrying a little
academic briefcases.
Uh,
they pick out everybody
practically who is young and,
and who is not white.
And so th this rubs people the
wrong way to say the least.
And it's part of the way
this works in the suburbs.
And so this incident,
which involved a police car was not
coming in sort of saying up against the
wall,
you know,
MF and all this,
but let's see your papers.
Uh,
cause that's what happens.
And I've seen that happen.
Uh,
it was just unfortunately these two
policemen who were doing anything wrong.
I mean,
they were just,
it was a banal trip
through a banal suburb.
I happened to hit these two,
two kids who were not wearing helmets.
And so they were killed.
But this is,
you know,
the,
I mean,
who knows what it's
going to happen in this,
but this is part of when
you see La [inaudible] hate,
you.
See,
that's the best translation.
Simply evidence is hatred or hate.
And to understand how
people in the suburbs feel,
you have to understand the
relationship between both,
and I'm going to do this
again in more detail.
I'd better get to what I'm doing today,
uh,
but,
um,
that it's not just young
people with not many,
not much of a future.
Uh,
it also is a,
mostly has to do with underprivileged
and underappreciated minorities,
uh,
pitted against,
the,
the crs,
the national kind of military police
as well as the municipal police.
And of course,
what the,
what the government of
of act did was of course,
take away all the money virtually
for voluntary associations that,
that our bridges to helping
integrate people in,
into,
uh,
into the communities in which they live
and into the state in which they live.
But,
uh,
you know,
say five,
you don't come with the office phone say,
I mean,
it's just a,
Oh,
well,
there we go.
Um,
how did we get out of that?
We got on that because it's
important to talk about,
uh,
Ali.
So today I'm going to talk
about Charles de Gaulle,
uh,
in November,
1970,
it's a passive eaten of the tall.
Uh,
I was a student in Paris,
just a little older than you and
living in a 11 frank and night hotel.
And the room is still,
the price that was about $2
a night in my hotel room.
Wasn't worth that actually,
but it was kind of an
interesting place to live.
Uh,
a four then I was living in Limos,
uh,
for a lot of the year to,
um,
I went to the archives one day about,
you know,
get there early,
which I always do.
And this little man who had been
with World War Two veteran who would,
uh,
lost most of his arm in the war,
who would check my id,
but he knew me.
So there's no problem.
Uh,
my wife used to come in and looking for
me when she was my wife Carrie carrying
a baby and the groceries,
and it's all very,
very,
they call track TAVR and foremost,
not that way anymore.
And he said,
we're going to close because,
uh,
this agenda,
Hala Lily Mar,
the generalist dead and
Charles de Gaulle died.
I had died.
Uh,
and I,
I think infuriated my gaullist friend by
saying that he died board and watching
French TV,
but he was often called on Bailey.
They do the uglies and he had a,
he had died at age.
He must've just been 80,
wasn't he 80 when he died?
Do you remember?
You don't remember.
But anyway,
I think he was 80 when he,
when he died.
Um,
and so,
uh,
later my gaullist friend,
who's a lawyer,
a lawyer called me up and said,
look,
why don't we go down in notes,
go dom and the go to the mass.
So the gold didn't want to have a mass.
And,
uh,
I didn't really want to go down to note,
and I'm going to go to the
mass for Charles to Gaulle,
but he said,
he said that,
uh,
it'll be,
you know,
as a historical event,
we should be there.
You should see it.
And so I went down,
we didn't went down to three in the
morning and waited in line and then they'd
flown into all these people.
Haile Selassie was there.
Those kind of amazing to see high Haile
Selassie and the odious Richard Nixon
was there and,
and all these leaders with
rather minimum security.
This was not in high security time.
You could see people were carrying
machine guns up on the towers.
You could see people in the cathedral up.
I was about the only person that
anyone saw get frisk and going in.
They looked at me and said,
we want to check you out.
So they checked me out with
the long hair and all that.
But we got in there and it was a,
you know,
it was a moment of
[inaudible] history and uh,
uh,
it was something,
to see his influence on French life and
the memory of French life can hardly,
I mean,
the collective memory of collective
memory in French life can hardly be
underestimated.
Yet.
It was so long ago that he died,
uh,
and the party that,
you know,
the beard,
his name disappeared,
that even if someone likes soft,
cozy or before him,
uh,
Jukka show,
Haka would go to Columbia.
They dues uglies it's village and the
[inaudible] and in the east of France,
um,
to have their picture taken in
front of his tomb with the qual.
The Lohan a de Gaulle
seems like a long time ago,
uh,
but what he did in 1958 is of
course to rescue the French state,
uh,
and to define a,
in his own,
his own person edge,
a certain idea of France that he,
uh,
did he represented.
And to borrow a Catholic image,
the gall who was born in Lille right near,
as I said the other day,
right near the fortress lead
as a pretty Catholic town.
He was not himself a
practicing religious man,
but I suppose it's a religious image that
I somehow have retained in the back of
my mind from the days at the good
old Jesuit high school in Portland,
Oregon.
Uh,
that,
uh,
he saw himself as the
mystical body of France,
that somehow the whole,
that is his body,
his percentage,
his very being was bigger than all of
the parts that constituted the body of
France.
And he represent,
he represents in France
with his fairy existence.
And that this was,
this was how he wanted to be remembered.
And when he leaves power in 1969 in a,
after a rather obscure,
um,
election plebiscite really,
that that image still was retained.
There are really three elements
that represented his image.
Um,
and the myth of Charles de
Gaulle after world war two,
um,
that he was the providential figure who
through his own determination had saved
France and it's honor
after the blowout of May,
June,
1940,
uh,
that,
that as his voice crackled over the BBC
and the 18th of June 18 and 1940 a date
is still commemorized a commemorated a
every year when there's a ghost in power
and mirror mirror of France such as,
uh,
a Shafak.
There'd always been a little
event to commemorate that,
that he had restored
the integrity of France.
If my friend Bob Paxton,
as I remind you the other day,
a argued that that pay tie,
he might've saved the French state,
but he did not save the French nation.
He destroyed it by destroying
liberty fraternity equality.
And what that means,
uh,
that Charles de Gaulle had
restored the integrity of,
of France had restored the Po,
the sovereignty of French over their own,
uh,
over their own political existence,
which is obvious and the republic itself,
uh,
by being involved in the
curation of the fourth republic.
But then repudiating the
way it was established,
wanting a centralized executive
authority and all of that.
And then a golf pouting Toussaint,
uh,
to,
Columbian they do as the uglies,
um,
that he'd then he'd reunified
the nation after the civil war.
Uh,
that was Vichy.
But again,
with the goal is twist is that everybody
had basically resisted or wanted to
resist that they were always ready with
the gun nearby to go and kill the German
when they could and restore France.
Um,
uh,
and that every,
that hardly anyone had collaborated.
So this was the,
so the goal is take on this and that
he'd restored the centralized state,
not after World War Two,
because,
uh,
we're,
cause the force republic was as her swing
door ministry is rather like the third
republic,
which as in the case of the third
republic gave the illusion that French
political life was more unstable
than it was because the,
the deputies of the Fourth Republic,
like the deputies of the third republic,
it was a club where the same people were,
were,
you know,
reelected time and time again
from the same constituencies.
But the golf thing with it,
the only,
uh,
the only form of government that could
restore the integrity of France and,
uh,
in the factions of parliamentary
corals and poor lane.
And he hates you.
Hated the communists,
of course,
was a strongly centralized government.
And for that he had to wait
as new now know until sank.
Won't tweet until 1958 with a
constitution written for him by Michelle
[inaudible],
uh,
who personified gall ism itself and
whose son is an important figure in
contemporary France.
Um,
and that,
and this is very important for,
uh,
the goal of view of France is that he
had freed France in his mind from the
anarchy of political parties and,
uh,
that we're quarrelling a parliamentary
government that he didn't think he had
worked that was incapable of
restoring the grand juror of France.
A word he too,
which he returned
constantly more about that,
uh,
in a while.
Um,
strengthening the French state under a
new constitution that written by the way,
uh,
that,
um,
that gave France a strong executive with
a president who would be in power for
seven years and who had executive
strong executive authority.
Now those of you who know
anything about France before 1871,
if this doesn't sound like
Napoleon both and one Napoleon,
the first and in three Napoleon,
the third,
uh,
you know,
it's an obvious,
uh,
thing to say,
but it's still true that in 70,
there's no need.
You should know this was something you do.
1799 and the 18th of bloom Air Napoleon
Hill with the help of the Wiley I bay
cas.
Uh,
the,
the pre cas who wrote,
what is the third estate overthrow?
The assembly.
Napoleon had a bit of a
faltering and his brother,
Lucien,
I helped him out there because he
lost the only time in his life.
He really lost his courage.
Um,
they overthrow the government and imposed
a council it in which Napoleon becomes
the first council and
finally snatches the crown.
It is thought from the
pope and crowns himself.
Emperor.
Um,
and Napoleon adopts that,
what will become the most gaullist
political strategy and shared by that of
governments of North Korea,
among other dictatorships,
uh,
that is the plebiscite where you
ask people with a k a kg question,
do you agree?
For example,
the pulley and the third,
uh,
just before the fall of the whole mass,
at the end of the 18,
uh,
sixties in 18,
1970s,
a plebiscite.
You agree with the reforms that have
been undertaken by our glorious empire,
Emperor Cetera,
et Cetera.
If you write no,
you're saying,
well I don't really like reforms.
And so therefore you say yes
cause you liked reforms are yes,
cause you liked to pull in the third.
And so naturally the plebiscite
is like a South Korean,
I mean North Korean plebiscite where 99%
of the people say we sweating Napoleon.
The third did,
uh,
after he overthrew the second republic.
Um,
so there are strong
continuity's between Napoleon,
uh,
between Napoleon and the idea of
centralized state overcoming this of
quarrelling frack factions,
uh,
of,
of France.
And in the first put
an end to what it was,
was called the rather colorfully
and unfortunate phrase,
but the war of the chamber pots,
uh,
that was,
the French directory
before this whole thing,
this is,
is over,
gone,
overthrown.
And so there's appeal
appeal to the nation.
And Napoleon was,
uh,
you know,
one of the originators of an
aggressive kind of nationalism,
but Napoleon was perceived
as somebody over the,
on the left,
uh,
Napoleon the third,
and when importer's appointing the third
and 1841 wrote a book called a little
pamphlet called property,
uh,
about property,
about I'll call the
extinction of a popper ism.
Uh,
and the idea that somehow the caring
state cares about all people in France and
that p all people in France find part
of their identity in the notion of being
French.
And as you already know from
things we've talked about,
that part of nationalism
was the sort of aggressive,
uh,
carrying of the French language into
corners in which it was not spoken or
spoken only as a second
way of speaking language,
dialect in Patois,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
so,
uh,
the idea of a national will represented
in the body of a strong executive
authority is a Napoleon idea that,
uh,
that,
they'll pull pollyannic idea,
uh,
that became part of,
of the,
the political existence of de Gaulle and
ultimately of the goal is of Gall Ism.
But you had to have the idea of
it being ratified by the people.
Thus plebiscites now pay town.
The differences is that pay town,
uh,
in World War Two,
the national revolution in quote with,
uh,
the Marshall,
again,
the military connection,
Napoleon pay Petain as he saw it.
And,
and uh,
it,
the goal,
it was never ratified by any kind of
popular vote because it wasn't a thought
even more authoritarian
government under Vichy,
the 1920s and the 30s where the,
uh,
and the first half of the 1940 [inaudible]
was the wave of authoritarianism.
The cost,
the lives of so many millions of people.
I need not remind you.
And that Bonaparte's Ism as in golf ism
involved the kind of stamp of popular
approval seeing in the plebiscites of
19 eight and in subsequent plebiscites.
And he goes out in 1969 after he loses,
uh,
he,
they lose,
uh,
the plebiscite.
He says he on January 18th or no,
there must be,
I must have written this wrong.
It must be the,
these,
we just round the eye.
Uh,
it must be June 18th,
1940 he says,
I,
he,
he often said we the royal we,
but in this case he said,
I,
cause he wasn't yet running the show.
I General de Gaulle,
French soldier and leader and conscious
that I am speaking in the name of
France,
that I represent France,
again,
the mystical a body.
And he showed the bay again,
d,
e,
B r e a who wrote this constitution of
58 said that the only chance for French
democracy,
uh,
if that term it may be used is
to have a republican monarch.
And that was,
uh,
the Gaullist view of,
of the goal.
Um,
but,
um,
he resigned on the 20th
of June in 1946 and,
and the Fourth Republic
comes into existence,
uh,
with out him now.
Um,
when he returns to power in 58,
it was after,
uh,
because of the chaos of what
happened was happening in Algeria,
that republican institutions
seem to have been discredited.
And so he has the upper hand there to,
uh,
to identify himself with
the strongly centralized,
uh,
French,
a state.
It was clear in 1958 as it
had been clear with Napoleon,
uh,
though this as different case,
Napoleon one,
that it was only only de Gaulle at that
moment who could impose discipline on
the French army.
Thus the howls of betrayal when the other
generals say he's gonna make Algeria
Algeria become free,
and thus the sense of betrayal.
And they try to,
uh,
to kill him.
And so,
but for all of his,
you know,
verbal and his respect for an
endorsement of popular sovereignty,
but to his tool of state is
really often the plebiscite,
which is,
which is you can argue a serve a sham,
a tool of,
um,
of a democracy.
What and what he does,
uh,
in reflecting the fact that the early 18,
80,
the 1880s and the 1890s,
or the period of mass politics when the
first political parties are created,
I mean,
Napoleon first and deploying in third
did not create political parties.
Political parties did not exist in France
or they existed and the wigs and the
Tories a existed in England already.
But that is a long,
complicated,
a story that started,
it starts with the runup to the
English civil war at the end of the,
the middle end,
middle of the,
of the 17th century.
But he creates a political party,
uh,
that,
that will support him and
his support and the people.
A lot of the people who were gall us in,
in the late 1940s,
where people were part of the
[inaudible] of the MRP or whatever,
the,
the big Mass Catholic,
uh,
political party,
which was extremely,
uh,
a conservative.
Um,
but he,
uh,
the essence of this was,
was strongly centralized,
uh,
authority,
consciously
patterned himself after the
Napoleon's or after Boone.
Jay,
for that matter.
Uh,
he,
he been born in 1890 [inaudible] but,
but brought up in,
I think he was born in lead.
I'm sure he's,
I've seen his house in which I thought
he was born in legal that he's brought up
in Paris.
Uh,
he,
uh,
he loved the Arctic screen
off and he loved all the lead,
which is where Napoleon,
uh,
is,
um,
is buried.
I got it.
I just give you a small story.
I,
which I don't think I've ever related.
There was a famous,
is a fair,
most American tennis player,
uh,
who the first time this
tennis player was in the,
the French Open,
uh,
which is sponsored by the [inaudible].
Uh,
they took this tennis player on a tour
of Paris and the tour got kind of old for
this particular player.
After about an hour and a half,
uh,
person had seen enough
and then finally said,
some journalists said,
what do you like best about,
about what you saw in Paris?
And the tennis player said,
Oh,
I really liked the tumor,
the little dead dude.
And the little dead dude is of,
of course,
Napoleon.
And,
uh,
that image is still in
apoe two Napoleon's tomb,
which you see from above.
You can't see in the two of them.
It's not like when you're
looking at Lennon or something.
Uh,
but,
uh,
you know,
it is a massive tourist draw.
And,
and that,
that is something that's always happened.
It's always been the case since then.
Um,
he was a lecturer at a meal
at the Military College of,
of,
of here,
uh,
near Paris.
And he lectured on Napoleon's
military campaigns.
And particularly that of 1805,
uh,
when he organized the,
the French free forces
in North Africa in 41,
uh,
he referred to Napoleon's
campaigns that he had.
He had,
uh,
that he'd studied,
a very carefully,
uh,
but he knew also that because
the French constitution,
uh,
his head written written,
that is the third republic and of
the Fourth Republic had been written
reflecting the fear of
people like Napoleon,
the Napoleon's of Caesar,
Ism,
uh,
that he,
I,
he realized,
uh,
that,
that that was always,
um,
uh,
that was always a possibility and,
and always spoke highly
of things like popular,
a sovereignty.
He always used to kind of appeals to,
uh,
to the French masses that
Napoleon himself had done.
So effectively,
I'm about that in a minute.
And his sort of plunging into
the crowds to the horror of,
of his,
uh,
of his guards.
Something happened when Gorbachev came
to the United States and Gorbachev was
so,
you know,
such an impressive person
and such an underappreciated,
great man.
Uh,
and Gorbachev,
Uhh,
just shocked his guards by,
by getting out of the big black limousine,
uh,
near the mall in Washington
and sort of plunging,
giving high fives and equivalent Russian
equivalents of high fives that people
in the crowd when we're,
you know,
the,
the guards were just
scared to death because of,
you know,
we'd lost a Kennedy and,
and the,
and all of this to Kennedy's indeed.
And because of,
uh,
security issues and the gall who had
survived these various assassinations of
Tamsen one in which,
you know,
as I said,
it's just this huge man's car,
which is riddled by machine guns,
have a couple of guys firing and came
out and he escaped absolutely unscathed.
Uh,
you know,
Napoleon was only wounded
three times very lightly.
And Napoleon seem to have this view.
There's a guy that comes out of,
you know,
saintly [inaudible] romantic battling
figures in the medieval times that,
that they were the god and made
them immune to physical danger.
And that if somebody
fired in the 17th century,
bulleted,
such person that they could cast the
bullet as of Superman or some ridiculous
video thing,
catch them in their,
in their,
uh,
kits from in their teeth.
But part of this is the popular appeal
of this man who was full of famous things
that he said.
Uh,
uh,
he never attended his witticisms.
I mean,
they may have virtually no sense of humor.
he was a,
he's a,
a cynic but a very smart man.
But he,
and he's probably best
to remember for saying,
how can you possibly run a country?
I don't think he used the word rule run.
That would have been a mistake that would
have been left seem to the royal we,
which he used constantly.
How can you run a country that has 268,
uh,
different kinds of cheese?
It's also complex.
In fact,
there are many more than
268 times kinds of cheese.
There's probably 268 different
kinds of people don't,
which are small goats cheese,
uh,
produced in,
in the south,
uh,
east of France.
And in other places,
but what organized all this stuff
together and his thinking is that France
cannot be France without
gone Jew without grinder.
So one of the,
uh,
one of the compelling aspects of his
existence was that how you keep a power
that is no longer really a great power
in a world that had been divided among
two great powers,
how you keep a diminished great,
great power,
a great power.
How do you do that?
So there were two ways,
very vehemently anticommunist
through the whole thing,
but more realistic than the Americans
always more realistic than Americans.
And this will tie together in a minute.
Two ways.
One is that you maintain
forceful independence.
Visa vi the Americans and the Soviets,
the clash of these two,
these two civilizations,
both with their monumental exaggerations
and both with her monumental problems,
the American's problems
less bloody than uh,
the tradition in the Soviet Union.
How do you do that?
So you become independent,
you leave NATO,
you throw the Americans out.
Thus he's huge air bases that
were once full of American planes,
full of American air force people
and soldiers and Chateau Hulu.
And all these places,
I mentioned this before now empty,
just big parking lots essentially.
You can still see him all over the place
or Leon or there's another good one.
You're,
you're independent and you insist
on having the Foss [inaudible],
foss f like forest and the De de and
then for proper f r a p p d and a FAP is
not,
sounds like something has served
that coffee to it or Starbucks,
but,
uh,
it is,
the nuclear capacity
and there are so France,
it's going to be independent.
It's going to have a nuclear capacity.
The Americans had at atomic bomb,
the Soviet Union had to tell him like
bomb the Americans had used an atomic
bomb.
Israelis probably did not
yet have the atomic bomb,
but soon when I in India
would later and the Pakistan,
Pakistanis and uh,
as you know,
uh,
Chinese as well.
So that leads to point number two.
That is by being independent
and by being French,
that you maintain your influence in
places even as they are being decolonized
that place.
It's like muddy,
for example,
or Senegal or x,
Zaire,
the Congo,
which was,
you know,
the awful Leopold's private territory
before the Belgian parliament took it
over,
you know,
at the end of the 19th century,
beginning of the 20th
century because of the,
just the massacres,
the,
the slaughter of local people by sort of
Belgian in a mercenary types and all of
this that these places that even after
Algeria and before that Morocco and
Tunisia become independent,
that,
that the influence of La Belle false
in places like Vietnam after the French
leave because of French civilization,
the civilizing mission,
the French language Lennet Lebanon
and another very good example,
French influence in Lebanon,
a terribly,
terribly important.
And that this kind of influence,
a cultural influence and a
political influence of being
an honest broker between
these two big colossal powers
will help accentuate Francis,
uh,
existence as a,
as a great power continued
to exist as a great pocket.
But there's a contradiction there because
France was no longer a great power but
wanting to be a great power.
And so that was essential in the way
that the gall viewed Francis' role.
And personally his role that
France would maintain his,
it's influenced in what
they called in those days,
the third world,
TF monk,
uh,
that,
that were,
had just been freed from some of
the colonial imperial experience.
Uh,
but we're economically,
uh,
a disadvantage.
And that Francis historical
mission of caring civilization,
French civilization,
the civilizing mission,
et Cetera,
would continue in those,
in that context.
Now,
you even saw this very recently,
uh,
in the case of the Bulgarian nurses who
had been in Libya accused of as Terrell
complicated case,
uh,
of infecting a Libyan children with HIV,
with HIV and who had been condemned
to death and had been in prison for,
I don't remember how long.
And one of the first things that Sarcozi
does is he sends his wife was no longer
his wife,
uh,
to,
to Libya to,
uh,
use the influence of that
old French influence in the
Middle East to obtain the,
the,
the release of these,
uh,
of these Bulgarian nurses.
Uh,
and indeed they were
able to pull that off,
I think when the nurses was Palestinian.
But I think the other ones were Bulgarian.
I'm sure they were Bulgarian.
And in the,
I'm not sure about the Palestinian,
but if I think so,
and it works.
But this is an idea that we can be there.
We can,
we can intervene,
uh,
in these cases and get,
get things happen a lot because of that.
And no one,
if you travel in,
in,
in Africa and in,
in Francophone countries,
uh,
nobody should have any illusion about
the continued to influence a France in
these places.
And it is very,
very important.
And this is something that the goal,
um,
I believe very much.
He seared the domination of Europe and
France by Britain and the United States
using NATO as a tool.
And so,
you know,
you could argue now that that Europe,
quote unquote Europe,
the European Union,
the European community
in all of this stuff,
that the basis of this lies certainly
in what would have seen the 1920s and
thirties or format of
the 1880s and nineties,
a horribly unusual alliance
between Germany and France.
And the gall moves in that direction.
And,
and so,
uh,
and that is a way of,
of of,
I mean,
this is a way of,
of working against us.
We're wrong terms of circumventing
the kind of domination of,
uh,
of the u s uh,
and of Britain,
uh,
in all of this.
And what,
what he helps do,
and this is very important,
is it ends,
uh,
all that animosity between,
helps in between Germany and in France.
I can remember going up
to the Normandy beaches,
the Norman beaches,
and try waiting in there.
I imagine all these
people shooting at you,
uh,
you know,
in 6th of June,
1944,
when you go to Omaha Beach or Utah beach
or one of these places and it's full of
Americans going there.
It's full of very old
Uh,
you know,
to see where they had lost a lot of,
of friends.
But I remember going there
and then with German plates,
uh,
and this is in the early 1970s,
and still getting scared,
getting stares and,
and,
uh,
and insults that,
you know,
I could understand perfectly well.
They thought they thought we
were German and we weren't.
We were,
we were,
uh,
you know,
your age and,
and just kind of traveling around and
sleeping on beaches and eating a little
and drinking some wine
long the way and uh,
and all that stuff.
Uh,
but the gall help put an end to that.
And now that,
you know,
if you ask almost anybody,
uh,
cause you asked all the Germans
going into straws book to,
to uh,
to buy a flogging La,
uh,
or all the French going into,
going over to Germany to buy what
is slightly cheaper gasoline,
uh,
you know,
this isn't alliance and
the a cornerstone of,
of Europe,
particularly given the attitude of the,
of the British and all the anxieties
that they have about losing their,
their integrity,
national integrity of losing pound and,
and all that stuff.
Um,
and so,
uh,
the gall help make that,
make that possible.
He never forgot the humiliation of France
having been excluded from the allied
conferences at Yalta and Potsdam.
You've all seen those pictures,
uh,
of Stalin with,
with,
with Churchill and uh,
and sometimes Roosevelt as well.
But France was not invited.
Uh,
both Roosevelt and Churchill
just hated to goals,
guts.
They hate it as arrogance.
And he was not a person who,
uh,
who lacked confidence
and he was not Rigado.
He was not a,
you know,
he was not a good time guy.
His own family,
by the way,
his own family [inaudible] him,
his children did,
they didn't use to,
they used route.
I mean,
that's amazing.
Uh,
uh,
the goal and they hated him.
They,
they,
uh,
they had contempt for him and the goal
never forgot those personal humiliations
and the mutations that
law falls great power.
I was not invited to participate
in essentially the fate of a,
of Europe and the soul that leads to 1966,
uh,
France withdrawing from NATO by forcing
it to transfer its headquarters from
Paris to Bruce Mau to Brussels.
And these,
the army and air force bases in France
were closed and armed forces radio was
moved away.
So it was,
it became more difficult to
listen to football games,
uh,
on armed forces radio.
Cause you had to get them from,
uh,
from [inaudible],
which is an extraordinary,
a minor,
a minor point.
And again,
he insisted on the
development of an arsenal.
Uh,
that was nuclear and the anger,
the u s government by refusing
to support the US policies in,
in Vietnam.
And of course,
the French had already seen,
you know,
how stupid policies lead to bad results,
but the Americans did not see that for
a very long time until 70,000 American
soldiers.
And God knows how many,
uh,
people,
Vietnam,
uh,
died,
all of this,
he outraged.
And I remember this,
I wasn't in Quebec,
but he went to,
he went to Quebec and on a state visit
and he suddenly blurts out long live free
Quebec.
Uh,
you know,
and so this costs all sorts of problems.
This was in late.
Uh,
there's about 1967,
if I remember correctly.
Why Free Cake Quebec?
Because Quebec is Nouvelle Foss.
And that's where you
had 60,000 French men,
women and children living at the time.
There were 2.5 million English people,
uh,
living in,
what was the colonies in the
u s in a very one sided war.
But again,
the idea that if Quebec is free,
if it's independent,
my own personal view is it
ought to be independent.
So on by back.
But I mean,
you know,
it was just my feeling,
but,
uh,
I don't know enough about it
to say that's a good idea,
but I have the same kind of cultural
of feelings that he does about it.
But I mean,
this is not what you do.
You're not going to state visits suddenly
announced a long lived come back.
I mean,
American funds say the same thing.
If,
you know,
somebody came from,
I don't know if it was a,
uh,
some,
a Serb ambassador and an
Italian prime minister.
Somebody arrives and says,
long live new,
free New Mexico and Texas,
or something like that.
Uh,
people didn't view it very well.
Um,
and,
but although he was
vehemently anticommunist,
uh,
he did not want,
um,
he,
he saw himself as again,
this honest broker in,
in negotiating,
uh,
between,
the,
these powers.
Um,
you know,
his legacy were of these imperatives that
he had that were backed by deeds or at
least attempts to restore the grand juror,
uh,
of France.
Uh,
it's,
it's efficient.
Kind of active independence is a guest
that Stanley Hoffman called it that once,
uh,
and this diverse diverged from
other parts of the French,
right?
Look,
she a home magazine for example,
which is always just almost comically
pro-American on every issue.
The French right couldn't,
what to gall did is he took the
note nationalism of Napoleon's Le,
the Napoleon's,
which was nationalism associated
with the general liberal left.
The state will do good things for people.
He transforms that,
uh,
in the evolution that you see in
the third republic to nationalism,
moving to the nationalism of the right
into the equivalent of the union.
This sacred union of World War One,
a into a nationalisms have fundamentally
a nationalism of the right in France.
And part of that,
to make a long story short,
is you already have seen is
based upon his anti-communism.
But at the same time,
you have all this business
about grand juror and Gloria,
et Cetera,
a grand jury more than glory,
but in attention to,
uh,
even at the end of what's
called the glorious 30 years,
the French economy takes off that you've
read about in attention to how do you
modernize France?
How do you make it more economically
competitive and what you do about the
education system,
the university system in particular,
and that would come crashing
down on his head in 1968.
Uh,
so,
uh,
his,
his deeds,
his legacy in,
in I've already said,
I think what there is to say,
uh,
about,
the practical consequences of his,
uh,
his legacy.
But he,
he did,
I mean,
Francis influenced,
did a remain as a,
remained in the,
in the world,
which I think is a,
is a very good thing.
But the most,
the greatest legacy that he left his,
probably his style that of
the monarchical president,
the,
uh,
the king of,
of the republic.
The idea that he represented France in
a way that the sun king had represented
France towering over France and,
uh,
dead overriding the interest of those
he considered to be talkers mirror a
mirror.
Posers are talkers,
including technocrats,
the kinds of people who
had emerged in part out of,
out of World War II.
We're not out of,
uh,
under the fourth republic.
Um,
and so he left unsolved the question of
how you educate France for new society,
uh,
how you train and modernize people.
How do you,
what do you do with the
poisonous relations between
a very powerful Patois that
is employers,
uh,
and,
working class that in the 1960s was,
was still extremely influenced by,
uh,
the CGT.
He does the confederacy in generality
to lie and by the Communist Party.
So there were contradictions,
uh,
in all of this,
the idea that France is a great power
when France still in France wasn't yet a
great power.
The idea that France can be independent
and therefore maintain itself as a great
power by intervening by,
uh,
in terms of its cultural influence,
its political influence in the
third world and that sort of thing.
And the reality when push came to shove,
they were two great powers.
Uh,
so it kind of,
um,
uh,
the contradictions are there.
He said over and over again,
uh,
that he was not of the left,
nor have the right.
He was above the left or the right.
He used the above word,
a word above all the time.
Uh,
he said,
he says just Swedes,
Alma de [inaudible] these weeks.
I'm a man of the war of 1914.
1918.
He was wounded,
you know,
I'm Belgian bridge.
And Do,
you know,
as I said the other day,
and that was the sacred union.
When the,
in the interest of France,
these quarrelling fragments would,
would give up their quarrels with
each other and would rally around,
uh,
big France.
That Francis historical mission was so,
uh,
as a specialty set on a 10th
of a on the 11th of December,
1969 I don't want to oppose,
I don't want to even triumph.
I want to bring people together.
He saw his own party,
the art,
uh,
as,
as being above these,
he said that the,
the parties in 1965,
we said parties or organizations
constituted to show off
particular tendencies
and the support,
the interest of such and
such categories of people or,
or interests or desires and,
and this all,
all,
all stuff time and time again.
But he wasn't just someone who
is going to pronounce foolishly,
AH,
revert to the same,
uh,
the same,
eventually tired phrases.
He was somebody who believed that he,
uh,
he could pay potential,
attention to serve a particular
attention to circumstances.
And this,
he was rather like Bismarck,
uh,
or,
and saw himself in that way.
I think it's possible to argue.
And in this may be he stomps
off a little bit though.
I would,
I hate to make the comparison,
but maybe with Henry
Kissinger a little bit,
uh,
to,
in the old days,
but one of the results of the way he
viewed France I is that he didn't really
give a damn about the
existence of ordinary people.
He once said that,
uh,
state,
he said this literally steak fleet
that has steak with French fries,
uh,
is okay,
it's fine,
but it does not add up
to national ambition.
That's an exact quote.
And the business is,
or how do you,
how do you bring together,
how do you make,
retain the importance of a
people with 268 kinds of cheese,
uh,
was,
a part part of,
uh,
of all of that.
Um,
and so his,
his style was more original.
Uh,
then his,
uh,
then his doctrine,
I mean,
take the press conference.
He used to have press conferences,
you know,
American presidents often
over press conferences.
Those was the current one really
doesn't because the question is good,
too difficult to handle.
Uh,
uh,
but the golden,
it wasn't one for press conferences.
He hated them.
He couldn't stand them.
But the,
the press conference in the
old day were orchestrated.
They were appearances,
uh,
they were not like a
rock concert appearance,
but they were appearances and on the
left in which the questions had been
planted,
it was rather like FEMA,
whatever they called it,
an amazing senior couple
weeks ago in California,
they planted,
their people weren't in the room,
weren't reporters,
there were female employees.
And they presented it as a,
as a press conference where
one guy raised his hand,
he says,
why are,
why is FEMA doing such a
remarkable job this time around?
And then the guy said,
well,
I think we're doing very well.
Thank you for saying that.
It turns out that he was an employee of
Fema and there weren't real journalists
there.
Uh,
but the globe would do the same thing he
said he would do with real journalists.
He wouldn't do it with like Helen Thomas.
We once who was a wonderful person that
has had a guest at the t in Brantford
where she was always able
to ask the first question,
I don't think this is the case anymore
because she was the senior person,
but you had real journalists.
But they were told what questions to ask.
And then he would say he would give the
same kinds of responses that I've just
said,
steak freak,
do not,
and end up with national ambition
at the time of the Algerian war.
Uh,
somebody forgot to ask a
question about Ben Bella.
So he said,
did I hear it?
Said he suddenly looks up and says,
Dad,
I hear somebody ask a
question about Ben Bella.
And then he gives the response,
but he turns and reads a response that
had already been written for him and
sometimes by him.
Uh,
and so it was the kind of style.
So appearances were important.
The idea that somehow this mystical body
was connected in a real way to all of
you by national glory.
And when he would go to any town.
And he liked doing that,
uh,
he would go and he,
and he would say,
as I stand in the shadow of your
magnificent cathedral or next year,
smiling river,
French rivers are always
described as smiling,
bipap,
uh,
even if they're polluted by,
by,
uh,
by politicians.
Uh,
I,
I am thinking of you,
and I seen you here
are here to welcome me.
Your Heart's beating just as mine for
France and it's grand jury and its
civilization.
I remind that,
uh,
you know,
and then he launches into his two or
three minute bit and then he is in the big
limousine and out of loose accolade,
designees or wherever it is a,
and it all was like that were style,
increasingly overwhelmed substance and
in a man who was extremely elderly,
but in no by no means by no means senile,
not one bit.
Uh,
and who could still treat with contempt.
Anybody who came and told him something
he didn't want to hear but could be
charming as well.
Uh,
the stage was set for a,
his departure as time moved on.
And that would a swirl around the events
of 1968 a la revolutional malkay the
revolution that didn't really happen
in France and an involved awful lot of
people of your age and this to that.
After,
I hope a glorious weekend
that I will turn on Monday.